thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story the Prime Minister under
official investigation over whether he
failed to declare a financial interest
which could benefit his family
appreciate your next wife hold shares
and a childcare company which could be
boosted by the latest budget Downing
Street says it has been transparently
declared
also tonight the competition to Vladimir
Putin caged in Russia the British
passport holding activist sentenced to
25 years
body cameras for installers and a ban on
forcing prepayment meters on the very
elderly the industry action to be
announced tomorrow
Rupert Murdoch's Fox News accused of
spreading false claims about Donald
Trump's election defeat prepares to face
a U.S court
bring khaki nog brand new
foreign
we hear the new Welsh identity for the
Brecken beacons
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages that's in our
press preview from 10 30.
[Music]
hello there good evening the prime
minister's wealth is no secret neither
is his wife's but tonight Rishi sunak is
being investigated by Parliament
standards commissioner over whether he
properly declared an interest which
could have financially benefited her
akshata merti owned shares in a Child
Care Agency which could have made money
from last month's budget according to a
Downing Street Source Rishi sunak though
didn't mention that shareholding when
questioned by MPS number 10 says the
interest was transparently declared our
political editor Beth Rigby has this
report
this morning began in North London
talking about maths
we simply cannot allow poor numeracy to
cost our economy tens of billions a year
but now the PM facing questions about
whether his own declarations add up do
you have any questions on things that
are not related to maths
back in Westminster they had plenty
today the Parliamentary standards
Watchdog announcing a probe into the
Prime Minister over whether he breached
rules when declaring his links to a
childcare firm that his wife invests in
when asked about it in Parliament just
weeks ago
wishes to declare and respect of that no
I mean all my all my disclosures are
declared in the normal in the normal way
the PM not disclosing to MPS that his
wife held shares in koru kids when they
quizzed him about increased funding for
child care from which that company could
benefit
but he had declared the interest to the
cabinet office as required a point he
later clarified in a letter to the
committee Rishi sunak said I know that
there has been some major coverage
relating to the minority State my wife
has in relation to the company koru kids
I was being asked questions by the
committee in my capacity as PM I would
like to clarify for the Parliamentary
record that this interest has rightly
been declared to the cabinet office but
the question is whether the PM should
have told MPS when asked the code of
conduct states that members must always
be open and Frank in declaring any
relevant interest in any proceeding of
the house or its committees
will the minister set out why she
considered it necessary to incentivize
child minders to sign up with agencies
and what conversations she and the
secretary of state had with the Prime
Minister and the agency in which his
wife is a shareholder prior to the
budget
[Music]
um I know that the number 10 team are
collaborating with the commissioner to
establish facts and show that everything
has been transparently declared number
10 say that there's no case to answer
that the Prime Minister did declare his
wife's financial interest in the correct
manner to the cabinet office in a
perplexed by this probe but it is
nevertheless uncomfortable for a prime
minister to be under investigation when
he promised on the steps of Downing
Street but months ago a government of
Integrity professionalism and
accountability and it gives his
political opponents an opportunity to
accuse him of dodging scrutiny just
weeks away from a set of critical local
elections
a PM who wanted to show voters he was a
break from the past but his wife's
wealth again becoming an issue the
question is whether the public will care
Beth Rigby Sky News Westminster
well as Beth said what the Prime
Minister wanted to talk about today was
extending maths provision to all school
children right through to 18 what
teachers and students wanted to talk to
us about today though was solving the
school strikes and how to find more
staff to fulfill his pledge Becky
Johnson reports from Birmingham and then
you're going to do four times the X and
4 times the 10. if you add two more
years of compulsory maths after gcses
it'll equal a nation with better
numeracy skills according to the Prime
Minister as head of maths at this
Birmingham secondary amio Driscoll
doesn't disagree but she does question
the timing with strikes pay and funding
disputes currently the main issues
facing schools at this at this present
time I think you know maybe is that that
should be maybe further down the line
for discussion
um when there is such a big crisis at
the moment within the teaching
profession what should be the focus of
the government then I think definitely
um the retention crisis in teaching as
well and then uh the fair pay and until
those concerns are resolved there are
doubts over whether the plans could work
there is already a chronic shortage of
maths teachers and with many schools
struggling to recruit as it is some
question who will teach all this
additional maths the Prime Minister
accepted it'll take time to train more
teachers up but says his plan is about
tackling what he describes as an
anti-matts mindset so my campaign to
transform our national approach to maths
is not some nice to have
it's about changing how we value maths
in our country and changing the way our
education system works to deliver it so
that all our children get these vital
skills for Life what do you notice about
this what can we do to this it wouldn't
mean everyone has to do maths a level
and the details still need to be worked
out but rather than worrying about what
they'll be studying next year these
pupils are more concerned about strikes
affecting their exams I could be missing
on a lot of learning something
I feel like there's more important
issues than to be making students do
just extra tiers of maths like the
strikes and just everything else that's
going on
by moving the focus on to maths the
government risks appearing to be out of
step with what pupils parents and
teachers want to be talking about Becky
Johnson Sky News Birmingham
a friend of the Russian British
opposition activist jailed for 25 years
after criticizing the war in Ukraine has
told Sky News that she fears he will die
in prison Vladimir karamaza has already
survived being poisoned twice the
British government said it's looking at
extending sanctions against those
involved as a result our International
correspondent John Sparks reports
he's smart and articulate an outspoken
critic of the war in Ukraine and in the
eyes of the authorities An Enemy of the
State
Vladimir caramurza was arrested on
charges of treason and spreading
disinformation
but the 41 year old knew no mercy would
be offered here at his sentencing
his lawyer looks sad but her clients
seemed bemused as the judge said he'd
spend 25 years in prison
a sentence of unprecedented severity
given to a man for speaking his own mind
it's not Russia's War he says yet
another military Adventure by the
unaccountable unelected authoritarian
and frankly increasingly deranged
dictator in a Kremlin by the name of
Vladimir Putin here Kara Mirza speaks to
Sky News just after Russia launched its
invasion
a committed Democrat he was prepared to
criticize the regime at a time when tens
of thousands of Russians had decided to
flee
but the activist who also holds British
nationality was aware of the possible
consequences I think the best thing this
regime would like for us to do
is to give up and run away and we're not
going to give them that pleasure we met
him in 2016 as he entered a slate of
candidates in that Year's parliamentary
election
it wasn't easy at a party event we
sought the security services sneaking
aboard the boat used for the campaign
launch
the following year he was poisoned for
the second time and almost lost his life
he blames the security service
I'm really worried about his health
because
he survived after two attempts of
poisoning and his health is weak and
this prison will kill him outside Court
Cara Mercer's lawyer said his Spirit
remains undiminished now
when he heard the sentence 25 years he
said I realized I was doing everything
right
the UK's Ambassador said she was shocked
by the sentence
hold for his immediate release
basic human rights have evaporated in
Putin's Russia there is no room now to
challenge The Man In Charge John Sparks
Sky News
the energy regulator of gem will
announce that suppliers in England Wales
and Scotland have agreed a new code of
conduct on fitting prepayment meters
forcibly installing them has been on
hold since February after the underhand
tactics used by some firms were revealed
retina birchley is here with me Emma
this has been hugely controversial so
what will the code of conduct actually
say so it makes things very much more
clear they're allowed to be or there
must be 10 attempts to contact a
householder before one of these enforced
installations can take place there also
has to be a welfare site visit and
whatever happens no one over the age of
85 or someone terminally ill or people
with certain health conditions can have
this happen to them
um also what must happen is that every
agent that goes into a house will have
to have some form of recording equipment
whether it's a body cam or some audio
recording equipment so that will provide
some form of safety and it follows what
have been some incredibly high profile
file cases of people having enforced
warrants people coming into their homes
agents and forcing them to have these um
prepayment meters to claw back some of
the debt that they got into in a time of
a cost of living crisis and it prompted
criticism of the government criticism of
off-gem the regulator and even a very
public apology from one um energy boss
now campaigners have welcomed it on one
hand but they say that obviously 85 is a
very high bar to reach and also there
will be certain disabled groups who need
electricity they won't be covered so
there are some concerns but what it does
do is formalize the rules Emma thank you
the Gangland attack which resulted in
the murder of a man at a boxing weigh-in
in Dublin was like something from a film
carried out by men dressed as police as
a Police SWAT team today the most
prominent suspect on trial Jerry Hutch
was found not guilty the feud that the
killing caused went on to claim at least
18 more lives our Island correspondents
Stephen Murphy reports
Jerry Hutch walks free from Court
acquitted of one of Ireland's most
notorious murders
the horse decision Jerry step Plus
Jerry what's your plan now are you going
to stay in Ireland no reaction to the
Court's decision to clear him of the
Regency Hotel murder
that killing was straight from a
Hollywood movie played out for real at a
Dublin Hotel a hit team of Assassins
disguised as a SWAT team carrying AK-47
assault rifles stormed a boxing weigh-in
event at the hotel in February 2016.
their target was Daniel kenahan named an
Irish courts as the leader of the
infamous kinahan cartel
two other assassins one wearing a
woman's wig were already inside hunting
an eyewitness remembers the Panic that
ensued as we were walking out the door
we heard a group of people coming up
behind us rushing out and one person
exclaimed it's all kicking off from
there and we heard of chairs falling
over glass breaking and presumed there's
some kind of melee breaking out three
men dressed and guard a tactical gear
and carrying assault rifles immersed in
a van and came towards us and they were
shouting us get the F out of here get
the F down they're pointing their
weapons at us they're scanning the
people we were walking out with uh
checking to see he was coming out
essentially the gunman didn't find
Daniel kinahan but they did Corner one
of his lieutenants 33 year old David
Byrne he was shot six times by two of
the fake police officers dying from
catastrophic injuries in August 2021
Jerry Hutch known as the monk was
arrested by police in Spain and
extradited to Ireland charged with Burns
murder
52 days of evidence were heard at the
non-jury court today the judges said
they doubted the evidence of the key
witness in the case former Sinn Fein
counselor Jonathan daudos it was fatal
to the prosecution's case Jerry Hutch
was free to go
the murder dramatically escalated the
Hodgkin Feud which went on to claim at
least 18 lives nobody has been convicted
but the relatives of those victims are
serving their own life sentence
the the Regency and what followed had a
devastating impact on the people of the
North Inner City it's not going to be
forgotten too many people are dead too
many families have been affected by it
this is going to go on for Generations
the search for justice continues but the
monk has had his day in court and after
a year and a half in custody is a free
man once more Stephen Murphy Sky News in
Dublin
Sudan's de facto leader for the past
four years has told Kai news that his
troops will defeat the paramilitary
group challenging the military for power
Abdul fattah al-buhan was speaking as
civilians in the country's capital and
other cities took shelter for a third
day the United Nations says at least 185
people are now known to have been killed
our Africa correspondent Israel Bahia
has this report
thank you
violent clashes drove these students to
take cover
now trapped for days
one of them shows us their shelter in a
faculty basement they have limited
supplies and are unable to leave for
help
a student has been killed and we can't
move his corpse another student has a
serious injury the situation is dire and
we need intervention as soon as possible
and as he calls for help gunfire rings
out
all across the capital confrontations
between the Army and paramilitary Rapid
support forces have engulfed the city in
Smoke the two strongest armed forces in
the country head to head but days on
it's still unclear what gains have been
made
as the battle for power spreads from the
streets to social media
this state broadcast shared to the Armed
Forces Facebook has soldiers yelling
where are the rapid support forces to
the sound of Victorious music
videos uploaded by the rapid support
forces showed their officer claiming
control of the state broadcasters
officers and the state airport in the
northern city of merui
oh no
we got on the call with the Army Chief
and de facto head of state
okay the head of the Army is currently
calling us back
will you go to the negotiation table for
the stability of the country
it's possible he says if negotiations
will restore the country and are fare
then it's possible I ask him about the
presidents who have offered to fly in to
mediate talks he says the current
climate of clashes isn't suitable to
welcome them
with a closed Aerospace
internationally-led peace talks are
currently off the table for now millions
are trapped waiting for a resolution
that feels more distant than ever
Sky News
the play was stopped at the World
Snooker Championship this evening after
just stop oil protesters vandalized one
of the tables and tried to attach
themselves to another Robert Wilkins and
Joe Perry were playing their first round
match at the time of the incident which
saw a man climb onto the table and cover
it in orange powder a 30 year old man
and 52 year old woman have been arrested
on suspicion of criminal damage both are
in police custody
there have been more protests in Paris
tonight after the French President
Emmanuel macron addressed the country in
a televised speech and said he
understood the anger at his unpopular
decision to raise the retirement age
macron gave himself 100 days to heal the
country following weeks of anger after
signing into law his plans to increase
the retirement age by two years to 64.
he's now asked his government to open
talks with unions on a range of issues
the launch of the biggest rocket in
history planned for today has been
postponed SpaceX blamed a pressurization
issue for the delay and said a minimum
of 48 hours is required for another
launch attempt Starship which was due to
launch on top of the company's super
heavy booster rocket is a key part of
plans to take astronauts back to the
moon and on to Mars
well the claims were according to one
senior figure at America's Fox News
absurd to Rupert Murdoch damaging and
crazy but it didn't stop the news
channel broadcasting false claims about
election fraud after Donald Trump's
defeat that is the allegation made by a
company whose voting machines were
supposedly implicated and tomorrow it's
more than one billion dollar lawsuit is
due to be heard in court our U.S
correspondent Mark stone is in Delaware
tonight mark
Anna I covered every twist and turn of
the 2020 election where those claims
that it was stolen were first sewn since
then I've spoken to so many people up
and down the country who firmly believe
that it was stolen that Donald Trump in
fact won and for so many of them their
Source their trusted channel is was and
is Fox News
story about America's most influential
News Network we don't know how many
votes were stolen a story about anchors
whose words are trusted by millions a
company is called Dominion it's about a
lie a story about the 2020 elections
Dominion voting machines were used in
Arizona Georgia Michigan in this
Delaware Courthouse over the next five
weeks a jury will hear claims that Fox
News knowingly broadcast lies repeatedly
so
it's all about these voting machines
used Nationwide which Donald Trump's
team claimed had software inside which
stole his votes and gave them to Biden
delivering him the presidency Dominion
there were news conferences most notably
this one Trump's lawyer Rudy Giuliani
and then you can also trace it with a
very big spike in the vote count at
exactly that time and at the heart of it
all the allegation that fox parroted
this conspiracy to protect its viewing
figures and dupe its audience I'm not
sure that I ever imagined it would be so
dramatic and so pointed and so explicit
this is a huge deal for American
politics and for American Media and for
Fox and for the Murdoch's it's
potentially transformative
court documents reveal what the people
at the top of Fox News were really
thinking there is no evidence of fraud
none Fox's Chief political correspondent
Brett Bayer said on November the 5th
2020 two days after the election
later the same month the Network's most
high-profile anchor Tucker Carlson said
again privately this software it is
absurd
and Rupert Murdoch the owner of Fox News
after watching the now Infamous press
conference by Rudy Giuliani where he
alleged fraud by Dominion Murdoch said
really crazy stuff and damaging
and other private messages suggest they
did not want the truth to be on air in
response to a fox reporter fact checking
the fraud claims Carlson said in a
private message to two other key anchors
please get her fired it needs to stop
immediately it's measurably hurting the
company the stock price is down
all right the question for the jury did
Fox act with actual malice did they know
they were broadcasting nonsense the man
at the very top whose influence ran so
deep could be called to give evidence on
day one
look Anna I think the reason this is
quite so important is because it's hard
to overstate just how much influence the
cable news channels here in the United
States have both on the left and are on
the right of politics they are so
polarized and so hugely influential I
think that the defense of fox
Corporation will be will center around
the fact that they believe these quotes
that you heard there have been taken out
of context and are Cherry Picked they
are only part of the story so Fox will
claim that of course is if it goes to
trial this time yesterday there was the
dramatic news from inside the court that
the the trial had been delayed by a day
it was supposed to be a day underway
already but it has been delayed the
reason for that the speculation at least
is that Rupert Murdoch probably up in
New York and his team are trying to
settle out of court to prevent uh this
five-week trial from going ahead at all
we'll see whether that happens
indeed we will mark thank you very much
indeed for that
now I thought non-welsh speakers it is
quite a tongue twister the new name from
today of the national park formerly
known as the Brecken beacons they are
now banai brihanok and I'm not the only
person challenged by saying it as Dan
Whitehead has been finding out
for hundreds of years young and old have
headed up Penny van the highest peak in
South Wales but from today the park it
calls home the Brecken beacons is no
more a new kind of National Park not the
Brecken beacons National Park not
anymore no this place has a new name now
or rather an old one
adopting its Welsh name banay brachi New
York comes 66 years after it was granted
National Park status I think it's really
important to celebrate our culture Our
Heritage as you know as we've mentioned
the name goes back to the roots of the
kingdom of
um and Welsh language a culture is
really really important to us and to our
visitors
the name change is just one part of a
new plan for the park to improve
biodiversity and tackle the impacts of
climate change promoting Welsh culture
and language may be a big part of this
Rebrand but for the Walkers heading up
penivan this afternoon the new name is
proving a bit of a mouthful can you
pronounce it nog
have a go bad news
I'm gonna go with bam now Bryn kainiac
that's pretty close that's pretty that's
pretty close
perfect yeah but for the non-fluent in
Welsh fear not we're not saying
everybody has to
heinyog
ly they will but
uh be used don't get in trouble if you
still say breckenby
damn Whitehead Sky News
South Wales
well that was kind is it 10 coming out
we'll take a first look after his
newspapers in the Press preview
including this story on the front page
of the eye uh the headlines sunac under
investigation by UK ethics Watchdog
OverWatch shares tonight we'll be joined
by the Guardians Deputy political editor
Jessica Elgort and Harry Cole the
political editor at the song back in a
moment
[Music]